let's talk more about the 9 11
anniversary and where things stand right
now chad wolfe is the acting homeland
security secretary
mr secretary thanks for being here
thank you for having me 19 years after
those attacks
what's the biggest threat facing the u.s
now
well let me just say brett it's a very
powerful day i had the opportunity to
spend a little time in new york city
this morning with the vice president
uh with first responders with families
and and with survivors
and i think many many of us really
remember where we were 19 years ago
today so
i just want to acknowledge uh the today
and what it means to those of us that
are in the homeland security business
and and go to work every day trying to
make this
this country more secure from a threat
perspective
we still see a number of our traditional
threats that we that we battled on 9 11.
counterterrorism and some of our foreign
terrorist organizations that are still
certainly a threat to the homeland but
we see more of a certainly of a domestic
threat here
in the country as well over the last
several years so the threat has changed
it has morphed over the years
but we continue to do other work at the
department to confront all threats
not long ago i sat down with the fbi
director he said there were still
investigations in all 50 states in one
way or another about different threats
is the home grown threat the biggest
thing you're looking at
it's certainly one of them as we've had
success on the battlefield overseas
we've seen
our traditional al qaeda isis and other
specific threats sort of diminish in a
sense but that
lone grown or homegrown loan offender
that is going to do some type of
incident here in the in the homeland
is certainly a concern for the
department i know for the fbi and others
so absolutely that is certainly the
threat that we are focused on
today you've seen that in the last
several years most of the attacks on the
homeland
have become from loan offenders or small
cells of individuals so that's where our
focus is
but again we do all threats at the
department so while we may be focused on
one
we are certainly we do the wide range of
threats facing the homeland i just want
to play the sound by from the fbi
director about the bigger threat
from china take a listen the greatest
long-term threat to our nation's
information and intellectual property
and to our economic vitality is the
counterintelligence and economic
espionage threat from china
it's a threat to our economic security
and by extension
to our national security from a homeland
security perspective
do you see china as a threat absolutely
i agree with the fbi director 100
we're doing a number of things at the
department to address some of the uh
aggressive tactics by china we see that
from an economic security standpoint an
immigration security standpoint visas
so there's a number of activities that
we're partnering with doj and the fbi on
so absolutely from a long-term
perspective
china very similar from an economic
perspective
is a very much a real concern for us
what about the border situation
yeah absolutely border security and
immigration uh
integrity bringing integrity back to the
immigration system is also a concern so
we continue to build a border wall
system but we also
continue to make a number of policy
changes that are bringing that integrity
back to
our immigration system so we make sure
at the end of the day we want to make
sure that
individuals coming into the country we
know who they are that they are coming
into the country at legitimate ports of
entry
uh and then they're not coming across
the border illegally
sneaking into the country or coming
across in the middle of the night we
want to make sure we know who's coming
into the country
whether that's on our southwest border
or that's uh through airplanes
uh and in the air environment so we're
we've done a number of initiatives over
the last three and a half four years
uh but we're there's more to do and
we're hard at work on it uh
quickly on this issue are you concerned
that long-standing issues over the
border wall
immigration could stymie the efforts to
fund the government
next month they did before
right i think that's always a concern
but i think we're in a good place when
it comes to
funding when that for that border wall
system
we have over 320 miles that have been
built about 450 will be built
constructed by the end of this fiscal
year so the president has secured enough
funding to continue that border wall
system
i think there's always an issue of
funding the department of homeland
security unfortunately
uh homeland security should really be a
bipartisan
issue and it just hasn't been for the
last several years
unfortunately so we'll continue to keep
our eye on the ball but again the 240
000 men and women of the department of
homeland security are interested
every day in securing this homeland it's
what we do we get up we go to work
uh to secure this homeland so that we
don't have another 9 11 type event occur
all right mr secretary i want to deal
with this controversy that you're facing
and that is a whistleblower
investigation
the whistleblower complaint in part says
that you
particularly told a person working under
you to
stop going forward with intelligence
that pointed to russia's interference in
the election i'm going to read from this
complaint in mid-may 2020 mr wolf
instructed mr murphy brian murphy is his
name
to cease providing intelligence
assessments on the threat of russian
interference in the united states and
instead start reporting on interference
activities by
china and iran mr wolf stated that these
instructions originated from white house
national security adviser
robert o'brien the two men met on july
20 2020 at which time mr wolf stated to
mr murphy the intelligence certification
should be held because it made the
president look bad mr murphy objected
stating that it was improper to hold a
vetted intelligence product
for reasons for political embarrassment
your response that's from the dhs
inspector general right absolutely that
that complaint is completely false it's
a fabrication
uh we have been very clear regarding
russia interference in our elections
russia interference at any point we've
produced over 27 different reports over
the last 12 months i believe three alone
in the month of august
we've provided over 40 different
briefings in-person briefings to members
of congress and elsewhere
about russian interference in our
elections i've talked about it
i've talked about it on media
appearances such as this talked about in
congressional testimony and i talked
about it even this week
in my state of the homeland security
address so we've been very clear about
making sure that we call out russia and
the administration has been very clear
on this so
i have no idea what he's talking about
that is not the case it's not any
direction i have ever given we've been
very clear and again
we put out a report regarding russia
interference
i believe about three days ago so it
just it just doesn't make any sense
you know the chairman of the house
homeland security committee
benny thompson just within the hour
issued a subpoena for you to testify
in this regard uh because he says you're
avoiding testifying are you going to
honor that subpoena
so again very disappointed in that i had
agreed to testify on two separate
occasions in the month of august both on
worldwide threats and on civil unrest uh
what was occurring in portland um since
that time i have been nominated and
there's been long-standing practice that
as you go up for a nomination
that you don't testify on other matters
so what we have done we've offered the
number two at the department of homeland
security
to testify in my place and if not then
i'm happy to testify to the committee uh
once my confirmation process
uh goes through one way or another so we
have been very accommodating to the
committee
uh and unfortunately it's come down to
this so you're saying that this brian
murphy complaint
is totally made up totally false
absolutely i think you have to keep in
mind this is an individual
in this office if you go back to early
august
i received credible and serious
complaints that the ina office our
intelligence and analysis office inside
dhs was collecting information on
american journalists
this individual was in charge of that
office i removed him that's a bright
line for me
while an investigation an oig
investigation inspector general
investigation
is ongoing on this individual
he didn't like that and so we see now
the results of that
but i want to make clear that absolutely
what's in that complaint is
false mr secretary we had to talk about
it even on this day
19 years after 9 11 we appreciate your
time
well thank you